no  so  knight e3 has to be the move  but look what happened with rapport  he did play knight d to oh  he's too  too brave for his own good  no agree then again it's chess you you  make your own luck no he also against  fabi he was resilient against ding  of course he got some gifts but it was  also a position where ding didn't didn't  seem comfortable didn't find the best  plans  but yeah so far the problem she can't  complain and if he wins this one today  plus four  that would be very very serious of  course we're not there yet  no but  and anyway you cannot lose  never he should stay in the in the  competition and he's fifty percent  maybe he can't think once maybe he just  considers that he wants to play and and  then we'll see if he gets opportunity  the question is whether how bad is it  really  why does he think that it's worth  testing  this position what it is when it looks  probably he doesn't understand that it's  worse and maybe it's not so bad